it's business good morning my name is
hula your stove I am the director of the
Norwegian Nobel Institute in also and
the Secretary of the Norwegian Nobel
Committee and I am calling you today to
give you some good news I hope
in a few minutes from now it will be
announced by the chair of the Norwegian
Nobel Committee this year's top of these
prize is awarded to the international
campaign to abolish well I'm Wow what is
your immediate response well this is
amazing
I'm shaking this is yeah wow what an
honor I feel like after predict myself a
couple seconds you read the first two
lines of all the announcements which
will be made the aura is receiving the
award for its work to draw attention to
the catastrophic humanitarian
consequences or any used on nuclear
weapons and for its groundbreaking
efforts to achieve a treaty based
prohibition all such weapons I have to
run off to to the announcement thank you
thank you so much it's wrong thank you